[Music]
let's go to margot in chicago
what's up margo in chicago
hi dr john how are you good how are you
it is such a pleasure to talk to you i
stumbled upon you about two years ago
and i'm just
utterly obsessed i guess i could say
that makes my heart feel good thank you
thank you you've made me feel so good in
the past couple of years too i
appreciate all the work that you do
awesome so how can i help you today
so i have a question that kind of
i just need a help a little bit help
sorting out
long story short um
i'm trying to help my mom
feel better and not be so broken-hearted
and
myself as well by
some major disrespect my brother and his
wife had caused
within the last three weeks or so okay
um can i interrupt you real quick yep
yes please does your mom want to feel
better
yeah for sure
does she recognize that something has
happened to her that was wrong
yes okay all right cool i just want to
make sure you were trying to solve a
problem that your mom didn't think
needed solving okay
so what'd your brother do
long story short um just some like
back history so it's always been me my
mom and my brother since
20 years now my dad died when i was 16
and he was eight so it's just been the
three of us you know helping each other
taking care of each other always at each
other's back we've always had a very
strong family bond it's been a beautiful
thing um i considered him one of my best
friends and
so forth
um so about
four years ago i bought a house and i
told my mom and my brother come live
with me my mom
is older and retired and has been
retired since my dad died and uh i'm
like it's time for me to you know take
care of her
so she's living with me and then my
brother came to and i had a beautiful
furnished basement that i just let him
live in
because he's a good kid and um
okay so speed up the process a little he
ended up meeting this girl
and um they ended up getting married and
okay that's fine you know do your thing
but ever since i've been married it's
like she just keeps trying to take him
away in a way and further away and i
just don't understand why i feel like
she's come from a very
family oriented
place i don't understand why all of a
sudden
that's going on so my point is
he they've been very distant anytime we
have an event or birthday party for my
kids i have two kids and they're
obsessed with them as they should be and
it's just so disappointing they won't
come they'll come through obviously
um they won't show up at all and it's
not really like
my brother
so i've had conversations a couple of
times like what is going on like you
guys can we just get it together and
i mean you guys are 20 something years
old you aren't children anymore like if
you don't want to come just let me know
i said it kind of sit here and plan my
schedules around my kids naps or
activities or whatever may need to be
done they don't have any done or
anything like that so
you know i may be right for them to
understand that
christmas time came and um
after christmas
they i had tried reaching out to my
brother a couple times he wasn't
answering she wasn't answering i was
starting to get worried
and so i had just sent a text and said
listen if you guys don't respond i'm
gonna do
a wellness check on you somebody respond
to me and then finally my brother called
me and i could just tell in his tone
something was wrong i'm like what is
going on
and he just said he's like i'm
frustrated he's like every time we your
house he's like me and monsieur that's
his wife always get into a fight i'm
like about what he's like because she
just she doesn't feel welcomed
she just doesn't feel comfortable mind
you dr jean every time this girl comes
over she's on her phone from the minute
she walks in to the minute she leaves
so
hey margot i i can tell in just in this
phone call
you don't like her
i don't but it's because of this
i know i know that you are nice to her i
don't think that at all i don't think
you're disrespectful at all but i can
tell you don't like her
and it sounds like you had a very clear
picture of what you wanted this thing to
look like this thing being y'all's
family
and
i guess i just don't understand why we
can't all just be together and celebrate
holidays and it's not what it is is that
a problem it's not it's not it's not
what you're asking for is why can't
everybody's life be how i want it to be
why can't i have a picture of how i want
my life to look and why can't everybody
just live into my picture
and it's normal for somebody to get
married and get distant
it doesn't mean it's right doesn't mean
you love it you clearly miss your
brother
but it doesn't mean that it's the wrong
thing
see what i'm saying
you made this
it's not it's not a rejection of you
margo
it feels like you're taking this really
personally
well
i kind of am because
now
a couple of weeks ago
i had called him and i hit
the holidays
and i need help with my mom she's very
her mobility is not the greatest things
are getting difficult for me i've got
two a two-year-old and a four-year-old
that i'm also taking care of okay
is your mom still living with you now
yeah she is
taking care of her it's just it's
becoming a little bit harder so all i
asked for
because i'm trying to sell my house
was for her to maybe whisper him to
maybe hang out with her saturday and
sunday so i could sleep for work because
i work friday saturday sunday 7 p.m to 7
a.m who are you a nurse
yeah
awesome
and so i called them and it was like hey
you know
i was just wondering if you could help
me out with mom
i'm putting up the house for sale i was
like it would be a little bit easier if
you could hang out with mom for a few
hours that way edwin who's my boyfriend
could take the two kids and he could go
do his thing
and maybe you could hang out with mom
for a little bit that way i could just
sleep because i'm not going to have my
boyfriend take care of my mom and the
two kids sure sure so so get to what
happened so what happened
so he's like okay yeah for sure i would
say go home talk to moan say call me
back and let's get a game plan so he
called me backstage
and he
already i could tell he was just like i
don't feel like it's an appropriate time
to help you and i'm like
but it's more for her like it's not
really for me i'm like i need help for
mom i didn't ask you to babysit my kids
didn't have to borrow money i didn't ask
for anything for myself like i just
needed help with mom so your brother
didn't show up your brother didn't show
up for you he didn't show up for your
mom
right so then
my mom saw something on tv and she was
like could you buy me this i was like
yeah i'll buy it for you so i went to go
buy it and come to find out
her debit card client
and my mom usually i don't know why but
she let him hang on to her debit card
and they've been spending all of their
money for the last two years and their
rent
and their car payments on everything in
their
world
you know took screenshots i had to
confront them i haven't heard a word
from them obviously you're not going to
embarrass as hell tell me how i can help
how i can help
i just don't know what i can do to tell
my mom because my mom keeps trying to
call him he's not answering and i'm like
mom you're just gonna have to leave it
alone and she just doesn't understand
why okay
here's here's here's the full the full
stop truth okay
your brother's a thief
yeah and he's not a person of honor
yeah
and you are going to have to grieve that
at some point okay right now
you need to
have your mom move the bank account into
your into your name
okay good so he's cut off right
yeah
until he decides
that relationship is is
over it's on it's it's
ka put
okay any sort of calling or cathartic
like i'll tell you or confrontation
that won't make you feel better and
it's not gonna happen the way you think
it's gonna happen
okay
okay
so the best you can do right you could
call the police and report him as a
thief
they would probably he's going to say
mom's told me i could and she's going to
say i don't remember or i don't think so
but she's not going to put her own son
in jail and so you can call the police
you can do that um
but here's the deal
your brother is a thief and he stole
from his own mother
yeah and it's gross and it's sad and
it's heartbreaking and i hate that y'all
had to go through this
the question is more
how are we going to move forward
you particularly moving forward not with
him not in your life
you're going to have to let that picture
go
and i'm really really sorry
me too to shave
it's such a shame
but listen that anger
you've heard the story that line but
i'll give it to you again
being as angry as you are at him
is just like poisoning yourself hoping
he gets sick
yeah
all you're doing you know all you're
doing is creating chaos in the home of
your four and two-year-old don't give
them that
yeah i don't want to i don't want to
okay so here's what i want you to do
i want you to write two different
letters to your brother neither of which
you're gonna send okay
the first letter is a letter of anger a
letter of rage
here's what you did
the second letter is a letter of
forgiveness and here's all forgiveness
is
it doesn't mean what he did was right it
doesn't mean that he will ever step foot
in your home again he'll ever have
access to your mom or mom's money again
none of that
if you think about what he did he came
and threw a giant cinder block into your
lap
and said you know what sister you deal
with this
and all forgiveness is is you standing
up and saying
i'm not gonna carry your brick anymore
okay okay free yourself of that
and i know i'm making it sound way
easier than it is
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be brutal
you're gonna have to grieve the facet to
the fact that your brother is not a
person of character
i just threw a lot at you
tell me how you're feeling
no i mean i feel better actually just
getting it off my chest i mean there was
like a lot of different
aspects to
how i was feeling and i feel like i
in my own and i guess
i feel just very disrespected because
i've done a lot for him and
him to not even
margo
you were deeply deeply disrespected
you were
grossly
so i'm just getting tired
yeah i'm tired of home one day through
friday with my kids which you know i'm
grateful for that i work friday saturday
and sunday and then i'm worried about my
mom and he won't help me
listen listen listen listen
i wrote down right here on my notes
exhausted
have you been a nurse for the last few
years in chicago
unfortunately yes yes you have been
living in the in the depths of the
furnace of hell
and by the way you know we should do
let's
let's have a second kid that would be
let's do that right
and
mom's uh
falling apart right underneath our very
eyes
right
so none of those things we can change
what we can change is
okay brother's a variable let's out of
the equation
where are other places i can get help
i can get support
are there city resources are there
government resources are there work
resources
yeah is dad in the picture
oh no i guess boyfriend's in the picture
yeah okay or is he the kid's
dad yeah yeah
okay
um
he can take a role a more a prominent
role right so here's what we do let's
stop thinking about what brother's not
doing every time and let's start
focusing on the solutions because you're
right you're exhausted and you cannot
keep running like you're running
is that fair
that's fair
so i want you to build a wellness
strategy for marco
what does a world look like where margot
gets sleep what is a world where margot
gets to laugh every once in a while
where margot
yes she loves her kids but she gets a
night or two off from them
where margot goes on dates again
where margot gets help with mom
hear what i'm saying
i do
will you pro will you
will you love margo enough to build that
world
yeah absolutely and i know you can't
afford it and i didn't have time to do
it
i know all those things but i'm telling
you is
you gotta you gotta figure that out
whether it's trading with some of your
fellow nurses whether it's telling
boyfriend hey
we're not gonna play house anymore we're
getting married and you're gonna have to
get another job whatever i don't know
what it looks like
but if he's gonna be in he needs to be
all in
and then he's gonna be helping his
mother-in-law too
but you're trying to hold all this
together yourself and you can't
you can't
write the two letters to your brother
and then put them in a fire pit put them
in a shredder get rid of them
commit to not carrying that stuff
anymore your brother's a thief he stole
from you stole from your mom
and then be about creating a world where
margot
is well
you've been running for three years now
it's time
it's time
that'll be a great gift to your kids
to your mom
will be a great gift to you